[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa del espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un resumen de las noticias
más destacadas relacionadas con la
pandemia del cob y 19 soi santiago lópez
gonzález a continuación el sumario de
temas que tenemos para el programa de
hoy
eeuu celebró su tradicional día de
acción de gracias' millones de personas
se desplazaron para estar estas fechas
con sus familiares eso se ve reflejado
en largas filas y aglomeraciones en
aeropuertos en estaciones de trenes de
buses entre otros lugares públicos
lugares propensos para el contagio de
kobe 19 veremos cómo está el panorama de
este país si le puso en marcha la
operación de los vuelos internacionales
y también permitió el ingreso de
viajeros extranjeros al territorio
chileno el aeropuerto internacional de
santiago la capital del país es la
principal puerta de entrada hablaremos
de las medidas y los cuidados
estipulados por las autoridades en este
país tiene un informe reciente la
eurocámara le recordó a la unión europea
que le conviene estar más cerca de
américa latina y el caribe en esta lucha
contra la pandemia y en lograr una
vacuna de acceso universal para nuestra
región conversamos con la eurodiputada
subraya rodríguez ella nos da más
detalles de cómo puede ser esta lucha
conjunta entre bruselas y américa
latina'
pues comenzamos en eeuu como es
tradicional el último jueves del mes de
noviembre eeuu celebra una de sus
festividades más importantes el día de
acción de gracias una fecha en la que
millones de personas se desplazan para
poder visitar a sus familiares y también
para ver a sus amigos más cercanos este
año por cuenta de la pandemia la
celebración pues por supuesto ha tenido
que ser de una manera diferente sobre
todo para evitar el represamiento de las
personas en los aeropuertos en las
estaciones de trenes de buses y en otros
lugares públicos veamos
la tradición modificada por una
enfermedad inesperada tenés que bing o
el día de acción de gracias este año
genera incertidumbre y algo de miedo en
eeuu el habitual desfile de la tienda
meses en nueva york fue limitado a ser
visto de forma virtual para respetar las
medidas de distanciamiento social
guasave
[Aplausos]
[Música]
en esta oportunidad el desfile solo
recorrió unas pocas cuadras de la gran
manzana el día de acción de gracias es
una de las grandes fiestas que une a los
ciudadanos y residentes en eeuu aquí se
reúnen para cenar el tradicional pavo en
un acto de agradecimiento por las buenas
cosas que ocurrieron durante el año con
casi 13 millones de casos por kobe 19 en
la unión americana y más de 260.000
muertes por el patógeno este 2020 ha
supuesto un reto para el desplazamiento
de muchas personas sin embargo algunos
no se dejaron amedrentar y están
recurriendo a los centros de pruebas
para poder viajar y llegar a tiempo a
otras ciudades viajes que podrían
incrementar el número de contagios una
semana después boom aquí llegan regresan
a la escuela y pum así que esto está
ligado con lo que antecede en la
comunidad y con lo que ocurre a nivel
social y la pandemia también ha
dificultado la entrada económica de
muchos que han tenido que recurrir a la
generosidad de otros para poder comer
y luego de semanas y meses del hobbit y
todos estos problemas de desempleo es
lindo ver el sentimiento de pertenecer y
la forma en la que les dicen a los
voluntarios y a todos que se unan y
organicen todo esto me hace sentir
importante y merecedora de software hoy
a pesar de la crisis sanitaria los
estadounidenses ponen sus esperanzas y
agradecimiento para que las vacunas
existentes sean efectivas
vamos a conversar con cristóbal vázquez
nuestro corresponsal en la ciudad de
washington la capital de estados unidos
para conocer más detalles de esta
jornada festiva allí en este país
norteamericano
hola cristóbal allí en la capital de
eeuu cuáles fueron esas recomendaciones
dadas por las autoridades allí en eeuu
para todas las personas que se iban a
desplazar a lo largo y ancho de la unión
americana a lo largo de este puente
santiago pues las recomendaciones del
centro de control y prevención de
enfermedades fueron concretamente la de
no viajar fue lo que le dijo este
organismo a los estadounidenses que a
pesar de eso pues viajaron en grandes
cantidades también le dijeron que pues
obviamente se pusieran las máscaras para
estar con sus familias en espacios
cerrados recomendaciones también en el
número de personas que van a celebrar
este día de acción de gracias que no
pasará de 10 personas incluso una de las
recomendaciones era que se hiciera la
celebración en lo posible en espacios
exteriores para evitar pues el contagio
en espacios internos
obviamente lavarse las manos pero estas
recomendaciones santiago pues parece que
tampoco fueron tenidas en cuenta en el
día del black friday varios medios de
comunicación ya han reportado que mucha
gente salió a hacer filas para madrugar
y poder aprovechar estos descuentos que
ofrecen varias tiendas en eeuu esto a
pesar de que las tiendas obviamente
tomaron medidas de abrir más tarde para
las aglomeraciones y obviamente pues
fomentar los descuentos en línea para
que la gente comprará por internet sin
embargo pues mucha gente salió de todas
formas a tratar de pues aprovechar estos
descuentos
la solución que plantean estas tiendas
es que si no lo compran en el black
friday y lo compren en el cyber lunnis
cristóbal yo no sé si usted ha tenido la
oportunidad de viajar durante esta época
de pandemia y qué restricciones hay en
eeuu en cuanto a los desplazamientos
pero los aeropuertos los trenes los
aviones iban a estar para este puente
festivo abarrotados de personas que
quieren ir a ver a sus familiares que no
han visto a lo largo de todos estos
meses que restricciones había como es la
dinámica para viajar allí que sabe usted
al respecto
santiago el precisamente yo ayer estuve
en el aeropuerto rodríguez de acá de la
capital estadounidense de washington
llegué y obviamente pues las filas de
las personas pasando por los puntos de
seguridad pero precisamente en estos
puntos de seguridad hay unos plásticos
que separan a los agentes de seguridad y
a los agentes de las aerolíneas en los
puntos de chequeo de el público de la
gente de los plásticos para evitar
precisamente el contagio en varias
terminales de transportes aeropuertos
estaciones de trenes también hay sitios
para hacer pruebas rápidas de el cubil
en puntos de chequeo también pues era
común ver que aerolíneas ofrecían
máscaras obviamente gel anti anti
desinfectante y pues recomendaban
obviamente el distanciamiento social
estas eran pues algunas de las medidas
que vi en algunos terminales sin embargo
usted lo presionaba bien más de un
millón de personas viajó al día en estas
vacaciones del día de acción de gracias
y esto pues ha hecho obviamente que las
cifras de contagio en eeuu
lleguen a niveles récord y es que muchas
personas aprovecharon para viajar para
ver a sus familiares que no ven desde
principios de año y también porque es
uno de los pocos días festivos que hay
en eeuu donde los estadounidenses pueden
darse el lujo de descansar este país
también ha roto todos los récords a lo
largo de esta pandemia es el país que
más casos tiene en este momento es el
país que más personas fallecidas ha
tenido y también últimamente en los
últimos días se ha registrado una alta
tasa de personas hospitalizadas ya con
esto y con lo que se está viendo esta
semana pues en 15 días el panorama
entonces no va a ser muy alentador qué
cifras se esperan entonces que prevén
las autoridades en torno al contagio
santiago no es muy alentador y le doy
tres razones por las cuales no ha sido
alentadora tampoco esta semana la
primera de ellas es precisamente las
vacaciones de thanks giving mucha de la
gente en la ciudad es lo que hizo fue
irse a hacerse la prueba entonces mucha
más gente se hizo la prueba para poder
llegar sana y salva a sus casas con la
prueba negativa y eso hizo obviamente
que el número de casos aumentará pero
también lo que ha hecho que el número de
casos aumente es el black friday
mucha gente igual sale a los centros
comerciales y se contagia obviamente por
las aglomeraciones en estas tiendas que
ofrecen estos descuentos y el tercer
punto es el tema de la vacuna la cdeee
se dijo que en dos semanas se en dos
semanas en la segunda semana de
diciembre se podría empezar a vacunar a
varios estadounidenses sobre todo los
más necesitados y los trabajadores de la
salud eso ha hecho que la gente de
alguna manera se relaje y eso es el
relajamiento pues se ha visto reflejado
en los índices de contagio y obviamente
en las nueces en las en las muertes de
kobe y muertes de quabit que al día han
llegado a superar las 2.200 muertes
una cantidad comparable al mismo número
de muertes que hubo en los ataques de
pro hold ball le doy datos sobre el
total de contagios son más de 3 millones
de estadounidenses que se han contagiado
y pues más de 265.000 estadounidenses
han muerto por causa de la pandemia el
panorama puede ser muy distinto
cristóbal si las primeras semanas de
diciembre de la primera quincena tenemos
ya una vacuna circulando en eeuu el
panorama de cara al final de año puede
ser muy distinto muchas gracias por este
completo reporte de cristóbal desde la
ciudad de washington la capital de
estados unidos vamos a cambiar de tema
las autoridades de la ciudad de mexico
han adoptado una serie de medidas para
contener el rápido avance de la pandemia
y en la capital mexicana a partir del 23
de noviembre en lugares como oficinas
restaurantes gimnasios iglesias museos
teatros entre otros lugares públicos
deberán estar registrados y contar con
un código qr para que cada usuario que
llegue allí pueda escanearlo al ingresar
de esta manera buscan rastrear a las
personas que pudieron estar en contacto
con alguna persona
las excepciones son por supuesto los
menores de edad y aquellas personas que
no tengan un teléfono móvil
y en el marco de la cumbre del g20 el
presidente de méxico andrés manuel lópez
obrador abogó por garantizar que los
países menos favorecidos económicamente
puedan tener también acceso a una futura
vacuna contra el cob y 19 a través de la
eliminación de algunas de sus deudas
internacionales a continuación les
mostramos un extracto de esa
intervención del presidente mexicano
durante esta cumbre de líderes mundiales
la crisis económica que precipitó la
pandemia afectó la actividad productiva
y el crecimiento disminuyó en una
proporción sin precedentes en los
últimos 90 años hacer realidad el
compromiso de quitar montos de deuda y
del pago de servicio de la deuda a
naciones pobres del mundo garantizar que
los países ingresos medios puedan tener
acceso a créditos con tasas de interés
equivalentes a las que están vigentes en
países desarrollados
y ahora nos vamos hasta el extremo sur
del continente esta semana chile abrió
su frontera aérea y puso en marcha la
operación del principal aeropuerto de
ese país el arturo merino benítez que
sirve a santiago la capital esto
significa que también la entrada de
ciudadanos extranjeros a los que se les
exigirá tener una prueba negativa de
coronavirus y también un seguro de
viajes ya queda completamente avalado
por las autoridades hay restricciones
hay algunas medidas adicionales también
dependiendo de la procedencia del país
del que lleguen estos viajeros la
apertura de los aeropuertos
internacionales y las llegadas de los
viajeros de cara a la temporada de
verano puede servir como incentivo para
la industria turística fuertemente
afectada por supuesto por la pandemia
aún así la emergencia sanitaria por
cuenta el coronavirus se mantiene
después de cinco meses de continua
mejoría en la situación sanitaria
promedio de nuestro país y gracias al
esfuerzo y aporte de todos los chilenos
y a las medidas de protección sanitaria
que ha adoptado nuestro gobierno
queremos anunciar la primera etapa del
proceso de reapertura de nuestras
fronteras para los extranjeros no
residentes en nuestro país vamos a
conversar con patricia luna corresponsal
de france 24 en la ciudad de santiago
para conocer más detalles de esta medida
de apertura y el panorama general en
chile hola patricia como ya lo decíamos
pues chile se tomó su tiempo pero ya
abrió la frontera aérea y reactivó los
vuelos internacionales ya pueden llegar
turistas y también ciudadanos chilenos
que están en otros países como ha
recibido el país esta noticia
bueno pues era una noticia muy esperada
nueve meses después por fin se hable el
principal aeropuerto de entrada al país
en una apertura pausada que contempla
también en el futuro la apertura de las
vías terrestres y marítimas fronterizas
para llegar a chile desde el 18 de marzo
que se habían suspendido completamente
los vuelos y es un momento tan
importante como vosotros señala veis que
el propio presidente sebastián piñera el
domingo realizaba una ceremonia en el
aeropuerto para marcar este momento hito
se pedirán a los turistas que lleguen al
país tres requisitos un pcr negativo con
72 horas de antigüedad una declaración
jurada y también un seguro de salud en
caso de que contraiga coronavirus en el
país para que tenga prestaciones
sanitarias adecuadas además tendrá que
estar contact able durante un periodo de
diez días por las autoridades sanitarias
e ir reportando en el caso de países de
alto contagio según la organización
mundial de la salud tendrá que guardar
una cuarentena y estas medidas se van a
revaluar el próximo 7
si le espera con esto que 300.000
personas lleguen de aquí a finales de
2021 impulsadas sobre todo por el
eclipse que tendrá lugar el próximo 14
de diciembre y que será visible en el
sur del país y también reimpulsar el
sector turístico que se vio afectado ya
el año pasado por el estallido el año
pasado 45 millones de turistas llegaban
al país en una cifra que era inferior a
la del año anterior sin embargo hasta
que se cerraron las fronteras el 18 de
marzo sólo unos 100 millones de
extranjeros habían llegado a chile el
protocolo es muy riguroso patricia sobre
todo porque es que la situación allí
sigue siendo complicada sobre todo en
las regiones del sur del país que ya
usted menciona son las regiones a dónde
pueden llegar muchos turistas que van a
ver este fenómeno de el eclipse que es
lo que está pasando allí en el sur del
país cuál es la situación
bueno chile es un país muy diverso es
largo angosto que contempla diversos
territorios y muchas diferencias
mientras que la región metropolitana se
ve una situación mucho más tranquila que
la que se vivió en junio cuando por
ejemplo se registraban en junio-julio
4600 fallecidos y ahora en el mes de
octubre sólo teníamos 600 la casa de
positividad es un 2% es una de las más
bajas desde el inicio de la pandemia en
el sur del país se vive una realidad
completamente distinta de hecho seis
regiones del país se han registrado en
el último mes las cifras más altas de
fallecidos en todo en toda la temporada
desde que se inició el comité en el país
el pasado 3 de marzo así por ejemplo en
la región del bío bío en octubre se
registraban 144 fallecidos frente a los
59 que habían ocurrido en julio lo mismo
sucede en la araucanía donde había 44 en
octubre frente a los 39 que se registró
en junio y sólo en lo que va de
noviembre ya se han registrado más de 57
son seis regiones en total en el sur
todas la araucanía los lagos bío bío y
magallanes
y como también señalaba el ministro de
salud enrique parís en lo que vimos en
magallanes donde se vivió una segunda
ola de kobe de la que ya informamos aquí
el índice de contagios fue seis veces
mayor a la primera entonces el ministro
insiste en que si esto ocurriera en la
misma tasa en la región metropolitana
sería realmente catastrófico y que hay
que prepararse para una posible segunda
ola que llegue a chile a también a la
región central y no bajar en ningún
momento la guardia y mantener las
medidas de seguridad la alerta se
mantiene patricia y se guarda todavía la
esperanza que el verano pueda mejorar
allí la situación en el sur del país con
el buen clima
el índice de contagio disminuya también
recientemente el presidente sebastián
piñera habló esta semana sobre un bono
relacionado con el cob y para esta época
de navidad de que estaba hablando el
presidente de qué se trata esta idea
pues hoy mismo es el concreto esa ayuda
que consiste en 25 mil pesos chilenos es
decir unos 30 dólares por persona que se
distribuirá a 38 millones de familias y
acepta y total a 8 millones más de 8
millones de chilenos es una ayuda que se
da a aquellas personas que recibieron el
ingreso familiar de emergencia una ayuda
que se produce en un momento muy
controvertido cuando en el senado se
debate el posible retiro de un segundo
10% de los fondos de pensiones y se
critica al gobierno tanto desde la
oposición como desde sus propios
sectores a del hecho de que los chilenos
tengan que recurrir un poco a sus
propios ahorros es decir a sus fondos de
pensiones para salvar este difícil
momento en el que la crisis económica ha
sacudido con fuerza a muchas familias
chilenas parte inicial qué novedades hay
en cuanto a las vacunas en cuanto a la
farmacéutica pfiezer allí en chile
pues hoy mismo fighter chile anunció que
la próxima semana solicitará la
aprobación de emergencia por parte del
instituto de salud pública para empezar
a realizar la vacunación por su parte el
instituto de salud pública que
normalmente demora unos seis meses en
este trámite anunció que lo hará de una
forma expedita y que tardará apenas un
mes de manera que se establece que
aproximadamente a finales de diciembre y
principios de enero países podría estar
empezando a distribuir su vacuna entre
la población chilena esto sin embargo va
a llevar tiempo como ya sabemos como
ocurre en otros países puesto que a
partir del 2021 podría retrasarse la
llegada de dosis al país faisem en
concreto tiene comprometidas más de 10
millones de vacunas para los chilenos el
gobierno de chile también tiene
contratos con otros laboratorios como el
laboratorio de oxford con el que tiene
comprometidas 14,4 millones de vacunas y
también 8 millones de vacunas
adicionales de box
a iniciativa de la organización mundial
de la salud es decir hay comprometidos
32 millones de vacunas para una
población de 19 millones de chilenos que
se espera que lleguen de forma paulatina
en el primer semestre del 2021
patricia muchas gracias por este
completo reporte desde la ciudad de
santiago buen fin de semana con el calor
intenso que va a ser allí en chile en
santiago particularmente para este fin
de semana pero cuidándose del cobi 19
por favor nos vamos ahora hasta río de
janeiro allí unos 61 mil alumnos de
primaria y secundaria retornaron por
primera vez a las aulas desde que el
país cerró los colegios y las
universidades a finales del mes de marzo
aunque los contagios siguen siendo
elevados en este país suramericano las
falencias de la educación a distancia
ponen en peligro a la clase media de
este país que se quedó pues con un ciclo
lectivo a medias veamos
miles de niños cariocas regresan a las
aulas por primera vez en 8 meses el
martes las escuelas de río de janeiro
reabrieron parcialmente sus puertas un
total de 61 mil alumnos retornaron a las
aulas sin embargo son sólo los alumnos
de último año de primaria y secundaria
quienes regresan y lo hacen bajo un
modelo híbrido cada grupo cada grupo
tendrá dos días de clases presenciales
durante tres horas cada día y durante
toda la semana los días que no estén en
actividad presencial seguirán estudiando
online y esas clases serán guiadas por
nuestros maestros brasil suspendió las
clases presenciales en marzo tras un
aumento de los contagios sin embargo la
necesidad de retornar a clases se hace
cada vez más evidente por las falencias
en la educación a distancia el estándar
están teniendo dificultades porque
simplemente pasaban mucho tiempo fuera
de las aulas y todo es nuevo para los
profes tanto para nosotros los
profesores como para los alumnos no
tenía la costumbre de estudiar en casa
sin la guía de un profesor
efe
a pesar de todo el buen trabajo online
de los profesores un trabajo con mucha
dedicación tanto de profesores como
alumnos nada reemplaza el aula nada
reemplaza el hecho de estar juntos no
obstante médicos y sindicatos de
maestros se oponen a la reapertura por
considerar que no existen las garantías
para la salud de los alumnos con más de
6 millones de casos y 170 mil fallecidos
el gigante latinoamericano es el tercer
país con mayor índice de contagios y de
muertes en el mundo
y vamos a seguir en brasil porque esta
semana el gigante suramericano llegó a
los 6.2 millones de casos confirmados de
kobe 19 los fallecidos ya rondan allí
los 171 mil según el ministerio de salud
de este país después de eeuu e india
brasil es el tercer país más afectado en
el mundo por la pandemia en espacio de
24 horas contabilizaron en este país más
de 37 mil nuevos casos lo que alerta
sobre la rapidez de contagio de cara a
la llegada del verano austral el estado
de sao paulo que es el más poblado del
país que tiene 46 millones de habitantes
es el que está presentando la situación
más crítica
y la muerte y el funeral del futbolista
argentino diego armando maradona generó
caos en argentina miles de aficionados
se olvidaron de por completo de la
pandemia y del coronal virus y salieron
a las calles del centro de buenos aires
particularmente a las inmediaciones de
la céntrica plaza de mayo- y de la casa
rosada- para asistir al funeral de
maradona en el lugar no fue respetado el
distanciamiento social tampoco el uso de
la mascarilla y hubo aglomeraciones que
tuvieron que ser dispersadas por las
autoridades natalio cosoi nuestro
corresponsables en buenos aires nos
cuenta más en el siguiente reporte
puede haber varios ángulos para pensar
lo que fueron las despedidas a diego
armando maradona por supuesto por un
lado la tristeza y la emoción de los
hinchas de su familia de sus seguidores
de las figuras públicas de argentina y
el mundo pero también se puede poner el
eje sobre lo que fue la organización de
esa despedida masiva ese velatorio
público en la casa rosada- la casa de
gobierno de argentina y no faltaron
críticas por un lado por los incidentes
que ocurrieron los choques entre la
gente que había concurrido al lugar
miles de personas y la policía el
descontrol que hubo en un momento que
significó que alguna gente saltó la
valla de la casa rosada- ingresó al
lugar hubo un poco de descontrol al
interior de la casa de gobierno eso
llevó a que se cerrara en forma
anticipada el velatorio por un lado está
eso y por otro lado en el contexto de
esta pandemia de kobe 19 preguntas sobre
si realmente era seguro organizar algo
así porque realmente la posibilidad de
controlar los contactos entre las
personas era muy limitada aquellos que
estaban en la
la fila estaba muy cerca había abrazos
entre extraños mucha gente usaba
barbijos tapabocas otros no
entonces ese cuestionamiento también
está presente si se quiere a estas dos
cosas el gobierno respondió con lo mismo
y es que si no organizaban ellos algo
probablemente dicen hubiera sido peor si
se dejaba librado a la organización
espontánea de la población hasta lo
consoló reportando nos desde buenos
aires en nuestra sección en redes veamos
otras noticias destacadas de la semana
aquí en kobe 19 la semana en américa
bolivia gestiona vacunas contra el cob y
19 para el primer trimestre del 2021 de
acuerdo con este artículo este país ya
ha desarrollado contactos fructíferos
con organismos internacionales para
aplicar la vacuna entre las opcionadas
estará desarrollada por oxford
astrazéneca y la rusa es pudding be
según indican las autoridades bolivianas
ambas vacunas son avaladas por la ope s
y miren este artículo porque costa rica
no buscaría la vacuna china ni rusa
contra el kobe 19 el país
centroamericano se decantará por las
vacunas que pasen por el estudio de una
agencia de regulación estricta como por
ejemplo la administración de alimentos y
medicamentos de eeuu
costa rica ya ha firmado acuerdos para
acceder a dosis de las vacunas de fisher
y bryant y oxford astrazéneca y el
mecanismo kovác facility de la ms
y nos vamos hasta sudamérica uruguay
superó los mil casos activos y la
tendencia preocupa el gobierno de este
país este artículo hace referencia a la
rápida expansión que ha tenido el kobe
19 en uruguay el país rompió también
otro récord de esta semana al
contabilizar 129 nuevos casos en
solamente 24 horas los principales
brotes tienen lugar en montevideo la
capital y en el departamento de
canelones
en otros temas la eurocámara le recordó
a los países de la unión europea que les
conviene estar más cerca de américa
latina y del caribe en estos tiempos de
pandemia y de la post pandemia en un
momento en el que la unión europea
necesita del multilateralismo es
indispensable ayudar a américa latina en
la lucha que está librando contra el
kobe 19 y entre ambas partes buscar el
desarrollo de una agenda en donde haya
una vacuna universal para todos los
países y para las dos partes y que sea
parte de esos temas bilaterales a
discutir conversamos con soraya
rodríguez ramos ella es eurodiputada y
nos dio más detalles de la idea de
cooperación y comenzamos por preguntarle
porque en medio de esta coyuntura la
unión europea-américa latina como un
socio estratégico al que debe darle una
mano
bueno sinceramente creo que la unión
europea y américa latina son socios
estratégicos tienen una unión muy
estrecha miles de millones de ciudadanos
de la unión europea viven en américa
latina' más de 6 millones y a la inversa
también ahí le voy a dar una cifra que
es muy significativa el stock de
inversión extranjera directa de la unión
europea en américa latina' asciende a
758 mil millones de euros
una cantidad que es más que el total de
inversiones de la unión europea en china
india japón y rusia-
me parece que dan una medida de nuestra
relación estratégica y de nuestra
cercanía en estos momentos estamos
renegociando acuerdos importantes con
países tan importantes como méxico como
chile
renegociación que sigo muy de cerca
porque soy la ponente permanente del
parlamento europeo para chile estamos en
la recta final
de mercosur y mantenemos un diálogo
continuo y constante no obstante dicho
esto le quiero decir que yo como
europarlamentaria española
me parece que efectivamente debemos aún
estar más cerca y debemos estrechar aún
más nuestras relaciones
también le preguntamos a la eurodiputada
rodríguez de qué tipo de estrategia está
hablando la unión europea para
aproximarse a américa latina para ayudar
a esta región seriamente afectada por la
pandemia del comil 19 veamos
sí como como usted sabe la unión europea
está sufriendo duramente las
consecuencias de la pandemia del cob y
19 pero vemos y atendemos con muchísima
preocupación lo que está pasando en
américa latina sólo el 8 por ciento de
la población que está teniendo un tercio
de las muertes mundiales sabemos por lo
tanto que la pandemia está azotando
duramente a toda la región hay algunas
algunos elementos las iniquidades las
desigualdades situaciones realmente
difíciles de poblaciones que viven muy
cerca de la pobreza o del umbral de la
pobreza que están sufriendo duramente
estas consecuencias porque como hemos
dicho muchísimas ocasiones la pandemia a
la cob y 19 no ha generado las
desigualdades pero las ha puesto mucho
más de manifiesto el virus o es verdad
que es el mismo pero no castiga de la
misma manera
las personas y la pobreza la desigualdad
social es una línea claramente divisible
en este caso por lo tanto desde el
primer momento la unión europea como le
decía ha observado con enorme
preocupación esta situación y hemos
acordado el 8 de abril de este mismo año
una ayuda especial de 920 27 millones
como parte del paquete team euro pero la
reaccionar la respuesta de europa a
nuestros socios para combatir la
pandemia y el banco europeo de
inversiones también 325 millones
quisiera también señalarle que la unión
europea es el principal donante de ayuda
humanitaria en la región en américa
latina y en este sentido también hemos
dedicado partidas especiales para
poblaciones especialmente vulnerables
estamos ahí sabemos que tenemos que
seguir estando en el futuro porque
lamentablemente la pandemia espero que
pronto podamos acabar encontramos la
vacuna tengamos tratamientos pero las
consecuencias lamentablemente van a
durar en los próximos años
y para terminar le preguntamos a la
eurodiputada rodríguez que nos diera en
detalle cómo podría ser esa ayuda por
parte de la unión europea-américa latina
en el tema de la distribución y del
acceso de las vacunas que puedan
desarrollarse para combatir la pandemia
del móvil 19 esto fue lo que nos dijo
pues
como usted sabe europa forma parte de
kóvacs que es una iniciativa que intenta
hacer realidad que la vacuna sea un bien
público global por lo tanto es el mejor
instrumento que contamos para que cuando
tengamos vacunas estas vacunas puedan
llegar a todas las personas
independientemente del país en el que
vivan
kóvacs
tiene como objetivo adquirir 2 mil
millones de dosis de vacunas de las
vacunas que tengamos las que ahora mismo
sabemos que podemos tener más o menos en
el mismo tiempo a disposición tres
vacunas diferentes cada vez que la unión
europea que está haciendo adquisiciones
de compra de precompra para los países
miembros hace un contrato con estos
laboratorios una parte del dinero del
precontrato va dirigido a adquirir dosis
de vacunas para de países que puedan
necesitarlo
y ahí está américa latina' nosotros
hemos dedicado una parte importante de
dinero 3100 millones a un opuesto los
países miembros de la unión europea
1.400 millones de euros la comisión
europea y el banco europeo de
inversiones ha hecho un desembolso de
dos mil millones y hará próximamente
otro desembolso de cuatro mil cien
millones para que se haga una idea de lo
que esto significa según la organización
panamericana de la salud sus
estimaciones
sin saber exactamente el precio de la
vacuna para sus estimaciones de coste
para poder vacunar al 20 por ciento de
la población de américa latina serían
dos mil millones por lo tanto esta
iniciativa kóvacs con la aportación
económica que está poniendo la unión
europea va a hacer que en muchos países
de américa latina se puedan adquirir a
más bajo costo y se tengan acceso a
estas vacunas estamos trabajando con la
organización panamericana de la salud
para que efectivamente en los estados
puedan adquirir a través de este acuerdo
de vacunas
a disposición y a bajo precio por lo
tanto creo que bueno tenemos que
fortalecer kóvacs pero creo
efectivamente que vamos a tener
importantes acuerdos de colaboración a
través de esta iniciativa con la que
también por ciento queremos si está
vamos a estar asociado el banco
interamericano de desarrollo y para el
cierre repasemos cómo va el avance de
las vacunas contra el kobe 19 veamos en
detalle entonces el porcentaje de
eficacia que han dado a conocer la
respectiva
las farmacéuticas hasta el día de hoy
así está la efectividad de las vacunas
oxford astrazéneca entre el 62 y el 90
por ciento le sigue sputnik vie de rusia
con el 92 por ciento la estadounidense
moderna 95 por ciento mientras que la
vacuna de la dupla facer variante que
también llega al 95 por ciento recuerden
que hay cerca de 200 estudios para el
posible desarrollo de una vacuna contra
el coronavirus
y así llegamos al final de este resumen
semanal aquí en kobe 19 la semana en
américa nos volvemos a encontrar el
próximo viernes siga con la programación
de france 24 buenas noches
[Música]